Marina: My first performance
was not in a (laughs)
It was nothing to do with art,
but I consider it was
the first performance.
I really, really was very ugly as a child
and I had this terrible
haircut over the ears
and I wore orthopedic shoes
and I have a child face
with a huge nose.
It was impossible for me to even
look at myself in the mirror.
I always asked my mother if she can go
to the doctor with me
and we operate the nose
and every time she would slap my face
and say, "Out of the question."
One day, I really made this perfect plan.
I was absolutely fascinated
with Brigitte Bardot,
so I took photographs from newspaper
and I had all the photos of
Brigitte Bardot in my pocket
and I had this plan of spinning
around fast, fast, fast,
falling on the edge of the bed was sharp,
break my nose,
then we go to hospital,
then I have Brigitte Bardot
photos already in the pockets,
so in the case of, "There's
no time. We can fix it."
I spin around, I miss the whole thing,
I almost gave myself a cut
and all the photographs of
Brigitte Bardot fall on the floor
and my mother arrive in the
room and just slap my face.
It was end of the Brigitte Bardot story.
I consider this pretty much
as the first performance.